dans le centre d'action sociale du
département des yvelines de trappes
il y à déjà les masques les
signalétiques de distanciation social le
gel hydroalcoolique à disposition et du
plexiglas pour respecter les gestes
barrière mais le syndicat mixte seine et
yvelines numériques
vous voulez aller encore plus loin dans
la protection les centres accueillant du
public comme celui ci seront équipés de
caméras thermographiques l avantage de
cette caméra c'est qu'elle permet de
prendre la température à distance donc
on respecte bien les gestes barrières et
on peut prendre plusieurs personnes en
flux presque tendu j'allais dire
puisqu'on peut prendre une personne
toutes les secondes
cinq cent mille euros ont été investis
par le département pour ces caméras qui
seront installés à l'accueil
les agents seront amenés à prévenir les
visiteurs de la présence de sept caméras
ils pourront décider d'accepter ou non
que leur température soit évalué sans
aucun contact et les données ne sont pas
enregistrées voilà son image qui
apparaît avec un bip sonore qui annonce
qu'il a donc une température au dessus
du seuil fixé par la caméra ici la
température élevée celle du verre d'eau
chaude utilisée pour la démonstration
mais si c'était celle de son corps un
protocole spécial serait mis en place
on va le recevoir et on va adapter en
fonction aussi de pourquoi il est venu
on va répondre quand même à sa demande
autant que possible on voit l'adapter
mais on va déjà lui donner un conseil
vraiment de premier abord en disant vous
avez de la fière on vous conseille
d'aller voir le médecin on peut même
vous aider à accéder au service qu'au
vide
proche ou le voir un médecin l'outil est
avant tout préventif et permet au
personnel d'adapter son comportement
avec les visiteurs les caméras seront
mises en place le 1er juin
d'ici là le personnel sera formé à
l'utilisation de la caméra et au
protocole l'accompagnant